today on the matt wall show some states
are reportedly considering a race-based
district distribution strategy for the
vaccine is this another example of
anti-white
systemic racism also five headlines
including the deadliest epidemic to hit
san francisco this year is not
covid we'll talk about that plus snl
actors sing and dance together on stage
without a mask
yet you still can't walk through the
grocery store without a mask
what's the science behind that and
finally a very somber and personal
daily cancellation today and much more
on the matt walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
i think one thing this year has us all
thinking about is the need to be
prepared
for whatever life might throw at us
whatever emergencies
might uh befall us and that's where
ready wise
comes in you know we've been talking
about ready wives for a long time and
now
is a better time than any to be prepared
with long-term nutritional food options
ready wise has many options like
emergency meals freeze-dried fruits and
vegetables for convenient on-the-go
nutrition
they have new adventure meals for hiking
and camping so even if it's not an
emergency but you're out
you know you're hiking you're in the
woods or something you want to bring a
quick meal
which is always a good idea then you've
got ready-wise that readywise makes
being prepared simple and affordable you
can order online and have nutritious
meals shipped directly to your doorstep
due to increased demand supplies are
limited some items may be out of stock
all that means
is that you got to order now don't don't
waste any time ready wise makes
being prepared simple and affordable you
can order online have nutritious meals
shipped directly to your doorstep
we're preparing our meals all you need
is four cups of water it's that simple
the water doesn't even have to be hot
you know you just
simply pour the food into the water stir
and cover after about 15 minutes
the meal is ready couldn't be couldn't
be any easier than that here's what you
need to do
for this for this especially this week
my listeners can get free shipping at
readywise.com when entering code
walsh at checkout or by calling
855-475-3089
ready wise is a 90-day no questions
asked return policy so there's no risk
taking the initiative to get yourself
and your family prepared today
that's ready wise r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e.com
promo code walsh to get free shipping
today
you know the term systemic racism is
like so many other terms in modern
society
used often and loudly and aggressively
despite having no clear meaning
naacp president derek johnson as quoted
in a usa today article a couple months
ago
has defined systemic racism as systems
and structures that have procedures or
processes
that disadvantage african americans and
if that doesn't clear things up very
much then glenn harris president of a
group called race forward
has said that systemic racism is the
complex
interaction of culture policy and
institutions that hold in place the
outcomes we see in our lives
nearly every definition you find online
is like this vague and circular
you know how do we know that there's
systemic racism because of the outcomes
we see
why do we see those outcomes because of
systemic racism
it should perhaps tell you something
that the clearest though still pretty
vague and silly definition
for the term that i could track down
when i was looking it up
was on the ben jerry's website the ice
cream brand
says that systemic racism is racism that
infects
every structure of our society now i
call that the clearest only because it's
clearer than
systems and structures that have
procedures or processes
but it's still completely obscure and by
design unfalsifiable
racism is being located in abstract and
unseen places
in structures and institutions the
proponents of this theory of systemic
racism
can't prove that the racism is there nor
can they often point to explicit
examples of it
but you can't prove that it's not there
you know you could provide a lot of very
good evidence that the racism isn't
there you know you could point out for
example that
a black suspect isn't much more likely
to be shot during the course of an
arrest
than a white suspect that in fact more
unarmed white people are shot by cops
and unarmed black people
you can as i have done go through all of
the shootings of unarmed black people in
a given year and discover that even in
many of those cases the unarmed suspect
was not really unarmed at all but was in
the process of trying to kill police
officers
or members of the public with a vehicle
or was you know trying to steal an
officer's gun or something
you could show that the statistics do
not line up with any claim of systemic
racism
in law enforcement when you look at them
in proper context but that doesn't
matter
it will simply be asserted that the
racism is there
somewhere in the institution in the
system
in the complex interactions whatever the
hell that means if you don't see it
it's because you don't have enough faith
or because you're racist
and that's really what it comes down to
that's the game if you deny systemic
racism
it's because you're racist you know you
can't deny it without proving it
if you think i'm joking the website
diverseeducation.com in a recent article
makes it plain says quote the act of
denying racism
is inherently racist the the denial
is the action that continues to
normalize mistreatment and further
divides the nation
this is sort of reminiscent of the old
test
to find out if somebody's a witch you
know drown them in the river if they
survive
it's because they're which if they die
well
one less which to worry about in the
world
now if i could i'd like to inject
perhaps a little bit of light and
clarity into this fog it seems to me
that systemic racism if it means
anything
must mean this here's how i would define
it
systemic racism is an explicit mechanism
put in place to purposefully provide
advantages
to one race at the expense of another
now i put the qualifiers explicit and
purposeful because it's not enough to
simply point out that one race is
thriving more in a particular system
than another
just because one is thriving more
doesn't mean the system was designed for
that purpose
if i beat you in a foot race that
doesn't automatically mean that the race
was rigged in my favor
but if i beat you in a race where the
rule states explicitly that i get to
start 50 yards ahead of you
then sure that would seem to have a lot
to do with the outcome
so in order to find systemic racism we
must find a system where it's stated
explicitly that certain selected races
get an advantage
while others some examples of this kind
of systemic racism
that is the real kind the provable kind
spring immediately to mind the problem
for the left is that
they're all examples where the racism
goes the other way affirmative action
prime example here we have a system
where the whole point
laid out explicitly is to provide
advantages to certain races
at the expense of others a white student
who doesn't get into a school because
his place is given to a minority student
with a worse academic record
is a victim of systemic racism
last week on the show we talked about
another more recent even more dystopian
example of systemic racism but it was at
the time theoretical
there were a number of public health
experts as documented in the new york
times we went over this
on friday according who are advocating
that the coveted vaccine be distributed
according to race
with priority given to groups that are
more heavily non-white
as one health and experts rather health
and ethics
expert so he's an expert of health and
ethics as he put it
it's important to level the playing
field by putting elderly white people
behind
racial minorities in line even though
the elderly of any race are far more
susceptible to the virus
than younger people of any race that was
the proposal that was the idea
now we find out that reportedly it's
actually happening in reality
the daily mail has the report this from
yesterday they say
quote every u.s state has been advised
to consider ethnic minorities as a
critical and vulnerable group
in their vaccine distribution plans
according to the centers for disease
control guidance
as a result half of the nation states
have outlined plans that now prioritize
black hispanic and indigenous residents
over white people in some way as the
vaccine rollout begins
according to our analysis this is the
daily mail again 25 states have
committed to a
focus on racial and ethnic communities
as they decide
which groups should be prioritized and
receiving chronovirus vaccine doses
now just to be clear about it um
the critical and vulnerable groups when
it comes to the coronavirus are the
elderly
the obese those with pre-existing
conditions those are the critical groups
and the groups that have suffered the
vast majority of coveted casualties
a young healthy black man is by no means
in any way
at greater risk than an 85 year old in a
nursing home no matter that 85 year
old's race
that's the reality of course but we're
not dealing in reality here
more from the daily mail says the cdc
has also issued guidance on its social
vulnerability index that uses 15 u.s
census
variables to help local officials
identify communities
that may need to support it's being used
in states such as michigan where
minority status and
language spoken could be taken into
consideration when deciding how a priori
how high a priority you are for
receiving a vaccine
maine in particular has developed a
racial slash ethnic minority covit 19
vaccination plan
in an attempt to give a preference to
groups that have experienced rates of
disease that are that far exceed their
representation in the population as a
whole
now all in all the male says california
hawaii
idaho indiana illinois iowa kansas
louisiana maine maryland massachusetts
michigan minnesota montana
nevada new jersey new mexico new york
north carolina oklahoma oregon
pennsylvania utah washington and wyoming
all reference
black hispanic and indigenous residents
residents as a priority
in their covet vaccine plans it sounds
to me
here like we have a system
giving advantages to some race over
another
or at least that's the intention now
whether there actually
is any advantage in being the first to
get this brand new vaccine
is another question altogether
personally you know i wouldn't want to
be first in line
or second in line or even a millionth in
line i don't plan on being in line at
all
because i don't plan on taking the
vaccine regardless
as a young and healthy person that's my
own choice
um sort of like going back to the
affirmative action example
you know i would be putting last in line
for college admissions
but i also happen to have no interest in
going to college and i'm quite happy
that i don't have the debt to pay off
that doesn't change what the system is
trying to do and it certainly is not
trying to help me
as a white male that's because the
system
is racist in these cases against me not
for me
now i'll be told that this is a good
kind of racism it's a just kind a
justified kind
and i'm a deserving recipient of it but
that of course is what the racists
always say
you know it's always a struggle for guys
when you start losing your hair and it
happens it happens to
almost everyone at some point as men
it's just it's one of the burdens
we carry i think of many might i add
and uh but here's the thing it is it is
a it is a tough thing to deal with but
here's here's the great part of it
you don't have to just accept it anymore
you've heard us talking about hymns and
how they're helping guys look their best
if you haven't yet it's time
time to see what they're all about 66 of
men start to lose their hair by age 35
once you've noticed thinning hair
it can be too late to really do
everything you can to stop it the best
way to prevent more hair loss is to do
something about it
while you still have some there hymns is
helping guys be the best version of
themselves with licensed medical
providers and fda approved products to
help treat hair loss
these are no you know we're not talking
snake oil pills or gas station counter
supplements
these are prescription solutions backed
by science hymns was created by a guy
who knows
some men's health conversations are
easier uh you know online than in person
no more awkward in-person doctor visits
or long
pharmacy lines four hymns connects you
to licensed medical professionals online
which could save you hours as well
completely confidential and discreet
they can answer a few you know you
answer a few quick questions
medical professional will review all
that and if they determine it's right
for you they can prescribe your
medication to treat your hair loss
and it'll be shipped directly to your
door so it's discreet it's quick
it's private and you're taking care of
the problem all at the same time today
hims is giving you the best offer yet if
you're if you're not happy with your
results after 90 days
hims will give you a full refund and
right now my listeners can get their
first
visit absolutely free go to for hims.com
walsh that's for hims.com walsh
prescription products require an online
consultation with a healthcare provider
who will determine if a prescription is
appropriate restrictions apply see
website for full details and important
safety information
remember that's for hims.com walsh
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
so uh really
fascinating and horrifying but important
report here this is from the daily wire
it says the number of uh
san francisco residents who have died
from drug overdoses during the past year
far exceeds the number who have died
from covert 19. a record high number of
uh 621 people have died from overdoses
in 2020 compared to the 173
who've died from covet 19 according to
statistics from the associated press
only 173 people apparently have died in
san francisco from covet
uh in two in 2019 441 people died from
drug overdoses in the city which gives
2020 the grim distinction of having
experienced a staggering increase of
more than 40 percent
the overdose statistics of 2019 were a
70 increase
from those in 2018. so the numbers keep
going up and up and and
yeah we know that the uh drug abuse
epidemic in cities like
san francisco didn't start
during covid we know that it's been on
this trajectory all
all the while but when you have a city
or society that struggles with these
things
and then you say okay you got to stay
locked in your room for a year
uh locked in your house this is what
happens
you know when you when you when you put
when when the
we have decided that the the number one
priority is just
to make sure that people continue
existing
quality of life doesn't matter none of
that matters
how much joy you get out of life that
doesn't matter
having a sense of purpose that doesn't
matter just
we're gonna continue existing
and this is what happens i just read
there was a uh another fascinating
thread on twitter that i just read a
moment ago before going on the air
uh a guy single guy talking about the
struggles of being a single person
during all of this
which is um something you know that's
that's another aspect that those of us
aren't single maybe haven't thought much
about but maybe listening to this you're
in the same you're in the same boat
or if you're a single person you know
you don't have a family
and let's say especially your your
friends
and and extended family are you know
sort of
more on the paranoid end of the spectrum
when it comes to covid and so you're not
seeing them much
and so what are you doing you're not
seeing anybody maybe you're working from
home
you're not seeing your family not seeing
your friends in terms of romantically
trying to find
a partner um that becomes very difficult
to do
so it's just total isolation not talking
to anybody not being around anybody
we know that uh that you know the liquor
stores have done very well because
people are spending their time drinking
and in some cases they're
developing hard drug uh habits at the
same time
this is what we get but this is all
being done right remember if you
criticize the lockdowns it's because
you're
you're some sort of sociopath i would
say
it's much more the other way around
all right number two dr fauci was on cnn
this weekend
um taking the important questions
and it's really good to see him focused
on issues like this
i think um here he is on on cnn listen
and elmo's back for something else that
i think is on a lot of kids minds
elma's friend has a question about santa
claus
how did santa get the vaccine
and is it safe for him to go in the
house how can
santa claus safely give out presents
with covid 19 spreading everywhere
how can he do it will santa still be
able to
visit me in corona viruses season
what if he can't go to anyone's house or
near his reindeer
well i have to say i took care of that
for you because i was worried that you'd
all be upset
so what i did a little while ago i took
a trip up there to the north pole
i went there and i vaccinated santa
claus myself
i measured his level of immunity and he
is good to go
he can come down the chimney he can
leave the presence
he can leave and you have nothing to
worry about
santa claus is good to go
you know you could say that this is
maybe the most credible
thing the most credible claim we've
heard from fauci is maybe that
that he vaccinated santa claus it's just
as credible as much of what else we've
heard from him
although i i will say you know
maybe you don't want your kids to listen
to that clip because santa claus is
supposed to be magical
he shouldn't need a vaccine should he
um on a more serious note a woman in
florida i believe was at a a
she was she was at a library i think
when somebody called 9-1-1
because she wasn't wearing a mask called
9-1-1
and uh here's how that interaction
happened okay
i think it's time for you to wrap up and
leave for today i think coming back
another day may be your best option
because today is not good why because
you've clearly caused a disturbance and
there's an issue
they just called because i wouldn't put
a mask on i wasn't causing any
disturbance i wasn't raising my voice i
wasn't yelling at anybody that's fine
i wasn't okay today i'm not trying to
okay get your books you can check out
your books and you can leave
okay
i'm not breaking any laws you're about
to be if you do not leave
what law would i be breaking because
you're causing a disturbance i'm not
in a public place i'm not causing a
disturbance okay
i'm not gonna sit here and argue with
you
what is your name i'll give you my name
i'll give you a card
you need to get your son and check out
your books and you can come back another
day this is not a good example
listen how how is this going to be
documented because i was not causing it
there's going to be a report done ma'am
there's going to be a report and you can
get a report number and you can take it
to your attention
please get your steps please get your
stuff before you get trespassed
did you hear there's someone in the
background you're not you're it's a bad
example for your child you're setting a
bad example
no i would say um if you're calling the
police on someone
because they're not wearing a mask and
you're scared you're scared
you're the one setting a bad example you
absolutely
imagine what kind of coward you have to
be there's a woman sitting at the
library and you're so afraid
you're huddled behind a desk calling
someone get over here quick get here
she's going to kill us all just get just
stay away from her if you're afraid
is it that hard to do did that library
didn't seem that crowded to me
so if she's sitting on a a table at the
library there's nobody around
if you're afraid just avoid her no
problem
i mean do you think if you're a hundred
feet away in another
you know in the non-fiction section well
she's over there in the in the
children's section
what do you think the trap the virus is
going to travel all that way it affects
you
absolutely pathetic i uh
of all the the villains that have come
to the surface during this um
entire crisis crisis uh
brought on you know self-made in many
ways
um of all the villains i have to put
number one
even above the petty tyrants in
government number one are
just the american citizens who are
calling the police
on their own on their on their fellow
citizens
on business owners or just moms at the
library
not wearing a mask those to me are those
are bad guys that's bad guy number one
right there
someone doing that all right number
three
snl speaking of masks snl had its
holiday episode
um this weekend kristen wiig was hosting
and her opening bit was about as funny
as anything else snl
has produced in the past decade which is
to say it was not funny at all
but the lack of humor isn't really the
thing i'm focusing on here
um let's just watch a quick clip of this
these are the actual real words okay
cream colored ponies and crisp apple
strudels
doorbells and sleigh bells and schnitzel
with nudes
i'm sorry i'm sorry you you you have a
beautiful singing voice but
those those words were crazy that's not
that's not cool what you just did no
it's not okay no i'm
cream-colored i don't need to say it
that sounds racist yes
and i don't know if i'm allowed to agree
with you but i do yeah you do yes
because it's racist yes
uh i i just i'm blown away by how
unfunny this is
look at professional writers at snl and
this is what they come up with
what what even is so the joke is just
that that was a whole joke that was a
whole bit by the way this goes on for
like
75 minutes it feels like and the whole
bit is just they take turns singing the
song the wrong way
this is what you come up with
professional comedy writers
hey you know what would be funny let's
have them all come up there and and uh
you know that that that song they should
sing it the wrong way that'll be funny
that's what they come up with but on top
of that let's putting that to the side
we're used to snl being aggressively
unfunny all the time
none of them wearing masks they're
closer than six feet next to each other
they're singing
you know projecting their spittle
forward
and no mask and to make it even more
absurd so if
you if you notice there you've got the
three women who are singing
no mask and then you've got you got the
the the band in the background
and most of them aren't wearing masks
except there's one there's one woman i
don't know what she's what what
instrument she's playing but she's all
the way back and she is wearing a mask
what's the point of that what's the
point of having a whole stage of people
people singing
you know playing the saxophone and no
one's wearing a mask and then you've got
one person
randomly wearing a mask what good does
that do at that point
we all know it's for show of course but
i'm just wondering what's the science
behind this so
if i well forget about me let's the
woman we just played she was at the
library
so she's at the library sitting you know
many feet away from the next person
on a road at her own table and uh and
she's such a danger to the public she
has to be escorted out of the library
by the police and yet these women
can be right next to each other singing
and everything and dancing and no mask
what's the science behind that what's
the science that would explain
how the one at the library is a threat
to the public
but those people aren't where's the
science there
or if i'm just walking through the
grocery store
not talking to anybody i walk in i get
my stuff
i leave never talk to a single person
which is what i would do at the grocery
store covet or not
as an anti-social person but um
and yet i have to wear a mask but they
don't
well the science is of course here's the
science um they are better
than me and you or at least they think
they are that's the science
i think maybe we can all agree but we
can't agree on much in society anymore
maybe
this is the only thing we can agree on
uh no but acne is bad nobody wants acne
that's
there there are very few pro acne people
out there
uh yet lots of people get it and uh what
are you gonna do once you have it well
proactive that's what you're going to do
proactive combines gentle skin care
paired with the best acne treatment
for your skin proactive has three
different systems designed for your skin
type
no matter what type of breakout you're
dealing with proactive combines gentle
skin care paired with the best acne
treatment for you
so they basically got three systems uh
to diff differentiate between
you know skin type and and what sort of
breakout you're dealing with they've got
proactive md advance this is a
prescription strength for stubborn
breakouts
they've got proactive plus gentle this
is for the more gentle sort of skin
types
and then proactive solution original
this is the original system
and this is for all skin types and it's
just kind of
it works for everybody with clinically
proven ingredients and tested by
dermatologists you're getting all of
this you're getting a simple three-step
system
designed for you and you can it's really
simple you subscribe
to consistently clear skin if you want
your skin to clear up proactive is the
way to go right now is a great time to
try proactive
for my podcast listeners you can get a
special offer available by going to
proactive.com
wall proactive subscribers will receive
the hydrating duo as a free gift
that includes four hydrogel masks and
the green tea moisturizer
you're getting all that free you're also
getting free shipping
again visit proactive.com walls to take
advantage of this special offer now
that's proactive.com
walsh and subscribe to clearskin
um let's see this is from ktla.com it
says san francisco public schools
won't reopen for in-person learning in
january because of a breakdown in
negotiations between the school district
and teachers unions over coronavirus
safety
the district said an online statement
the district cannot meet all of the new
requirements
that the labor labor unions have
proposed and there is not sufficient
time to complete bargaining in order to
reopen any school sites on january 25th
so they're not going to reopen and
remember we just play we just uh we just
talked about a few minutes ago
san francisco and their coveted death
numbers they've got more people dying of
drug abuse
than they do of covet yet they're not
going to reopen the schools
so we're ranking the villains from the
covet crisis
and i just said number one right people
calling the police and their fellow
americans
yeah they are number one um teachers
unions though
really really competing for that top
spot
talk about cowardice the cowardice that
not all but many teachers have displayed
during all of this is uh
really pretty extraordinary number five
huge controversy here
the lakers played their um final
preseason game on saturday
and anthony davis was spotted on the
bench
clipping his toenails um right there in
the arena you could see the picture of
it
during the game and he's just clipping
his toenails in front of everybody
now he's got a towel down this is a big
controversy and it should be
and this you know for me this is why
i've always said that all types of
public grooming
should be banned like clipping toenails
or fingernails that's
your you're you're a psychopath if
you're doing that but any anything
you see people cleaning their teeth i
remember not long ago i was out in
public and i saw someone i think maybe i
was at a coffee shop and i saw someone
flossing just sitting at a table
flossing
you know that q-tip anything involving
q-tips
all of that unconstitutional and uh
should be banned one of the most
important things we have are
our memories you know especially our
memories our old family memories the
things we're nostalgic for um
but the problem is maybe you have some
of those memories
stored on aging tapes film
photos that sort of thing and uh you
know those things are
stuffed away in a box somewhere they can
easily be damaged or destroyed
that's why you need legacy bucks legacy
box is an effortless way to have your
aging tapes films and photos digitally
preserved on a modern format
so they're safe for generations so many
of us have irreplaceable moments on
tapes and films and film reels
that we can no longer watch you know
maybe you know you just don't have the
you don't have that antiquated
technology anymore to watch it
that's why you need legacy box with
legacy box you can reclaim all that
priceless footage
you haven't been able to see for years
the service couldn't be simpler
you use their kif kit to safely send
them movements that you want to preserve
their team will create a digital archive
by hand
and then you'll receive your new copies
stored on the cloud a thumb drive on the
dvd however you want it
they're going to send it to you along
with all the original media you sent
them so you're getting all that back
uh if you wanna you know just as a
keepsake or something but you're also
gonna have
those memories accessible and safe
forever
with their tracking system you can
monitor every step of the process as you
so you always know that your originals
are being taken care of
and i've done this myself and the thing
that impressed me was how
easy and simple it was i mean literally
you're just taking all the stuff you're
putting in a box you're shipping it to
them
they're doing all the hard stuff and
then sending it back to you um that's
what i like that's
i like it when there's almost nothing
for me to do and that's the case here
go to legacybox.com walsh take advantage
of this limited time offer
and get 50 off take advantage of this
exclusive offer today and then use their
kit
now and send it in whenever you're ready
go to legacy box dot com slash walsh and
save 50 percent
while supplies last well
one other note here daily wires excited
to announce that the historical
docu-series apollo 11 what we saw
is now available exclusively for daily
wire members we were telling you about
this all
last week and now now you can go watch
it originally released as an audio
podcast for apple and spotify what we
saw takes a detailed look
at the apollo 11 mission to land a man
on the moon
now apollo 11 what we saw is available
to watch as well as listen
over at dailywire.com or on apple tv or
roku app
this series is just one piece of the
all the new content that we've got
coming down the pipeline including a new
show
with candace owens we've got the entire
prageru library we've got a new
entertainment channel
uh we're gonna have a new investigative
journalism team
that and much more but you gotta become
a daily wire insider or above member for
20 off with code watch
over at dailywire.com subscribe
let's get now to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation it
brings me great pain to do this as a
father it's the last thing i ever want
to do but i'm afraid i must say cancel
my one-year-old daughter i'd always
imagine that her time
her first time to be canceled would come
a little bit later in life my oldest the
twins were canceled for their first time
around the age of six so it's hard to
look at your youngest child your baby
girl and realize
that she must be canceled especially at
such a tender age but
it is out of my hands now for some
background
my daughter emma just very recently
started walking
and i could almost cancel her just for
that because children become much harder
to deal with
once they have full use of their legs
you know you can you can always tell the
first time parents
because they're the ones trying to coax
their kids to walk
at like nine months and getting very
excited about oh you got to walk
more experienced veteran parents know
you know we know what lies ahead
once walking sets in so we encourage our
kids to take their time
we say hey you don't want to start
walking until 18 months or so no problem
just take it easy down there
no pressure at all the problem is that
once they start walking
you know they can move around more and
quicker and they can reach things so
last night
for example my wife was out i was making
dinner and um emma was just walking
around the living room
grabbing everything she could and
tossing it on the floor
she grabbed a desk lamp at one point and
literally
spiked it on the ground lego football
and then waddled over to the coffee
table
chucked a cup full of soda halfway
across the room and they know what
they're doing too
she took that cup in her hand through it
and then looked at me like yeah
do something about it what are you gonna
do that's what i thought
punk this is what you have to look
forward to when they walk that's why my
favorite phase of childhood is
is when they're right between newborn
infancy and crawling
that's it that's a sweet spot there's a
span of several weeks
when they can't move much but will sort
of flop and scoot around
on the ground like a little walrus or
maybe like like a sea cucumber on the
ocean floor
this is enough movement to keep them
entertained so they aren't crying
but not enough to make them any kind of
serious flight risk so you can set them
down on the ground sit on the couch with
a beer
and just watch them roll around for 45
minutes without ever making it out of
the room
these are the moments to cherish you
know walking is
massively overrated in my experience but
none of that is the reason for my
daughter's cancellation the reason
can be seen in this incriminating video
which my wife took and posted online for
some reason we went to the botanical
gardens here
in the city you know that must have been
my idea to go spend our weekend there
um and uh and you know we were walking
around outside little emma was
doing more walking than she'd ever done
before and uh this is a clip my wife
took and posted somehow proudly
there she is walking along the path but
look at that arrow on the sidewalk
my daughter's walking in the wrong
direction
on the sidewalk they have arrows on the
sidewalk at the botanical gardens
outside telling us what direction we can
walk so as not to infect one another
with the virus
my daughter's going the wrong way
endangering millions of lives in the
process
i've never been so ashamed as a parent
now you might ask
why are they making their sidewalks into
one-way paths
when they're clearly wide enough for two
people to pass also
are you really more likely to give
somebody the virus while walking past
them in the opposite direction than you
are if you walk past them going the same
direction
in fact you might ask when you pass
someone who's going the same direction
aren't you likely to spend more time in
their proximity
than you are if you pass from opposite
directions because you know when you
pass going the same way there's always
that awkward moment
where you're where you're walking side
by side and you know one of you has to
speed up the other ones slow down
and besides is there any reason to think
that the virus is
at all being transmitted between people
outside who merely pass
by one another briefly and considering
that everybody at the gardens was
wearing a mask
everyone i mean except for my family
shouldn't we be even less
concerned about transmission if masks
do in fact work these are all good
questions
sort of like the questions you might ask
about why you have to remain socially
distant while
boarding a plane only to be seated in
the same metal tube with these people
for six
hours many anti-covet measures have been
adopted both voluntarily and mandatorily
which appear to have no reason or
justification behind them
that's all true but we're not supposed
to be
asking those questions just do as you're
told
wear the mask follow the arrow trust the
protocols
my daughter in a brazen act of disregard
for her fellow man
did not follow the arrows or trust the
protocols
and many lives have no doubt been lost
due to her recklessness
and she's not even wearing a mask on top
of it like i said none of us were but
she should really be setting an example
shameful absolutely shameful so she is
canceled today
and hopefully she has learned her lesson
from this experience remember
follow the arrows on the sidewalk it
will keep you alive
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadowsky
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nika geneva and
production assistant mckenna waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national
news cycle well tune in to the ben
shapiro show we'll get a whole lot of
that and much more
see you there